birds for me is listening to their sounds
and birds that have very nice sounds
that you know have a very simple sound
I think that being blind I enjoy
birds in a different way the sound of birds
for me is the way I have to
appreciate  this world
my name is juan pabló great ass and
I have been recording the sounds of nature for 14 years
I am blind from birth the only thing
I can see are lights my world is sounds
all the information I
receive in the first place is now to
see the birds  for me it's listening to their
sounds for a bird singing when
I hear their sounds in my opinion I
'm already seeing it with my eyes no I don't
need it I wouldn't need to see them
and
for me the sound of birds is music
the sound of 20  I see they have their
musical notes well established
the hornero has a very shrill song
it can be heard at great distances
later you have the tero with its very
famous sound than this lottery but all the
time
one of the  most melodic songs that
we can have in Uruguay, which is the
social thrush, it has a whistle that brings a
lot of peace
the importance of recording the birds is
precisely the conservation in the work
that he did to capture and record the
sounds of the birds is also part of
our heritage  natural that
unfortunately the human being is
destroying it so for me to record each
sound in a different place well it's
like having a record it's like having a
bit of that place in an audio file
and